[Music]
and those of you with young children may
want to send them off to bed the parents
who care if their kids watch the
simpsons were out long before the
treehouse of horror episodes in fact
they're probably cool with all the scary
stuff blood guts and dismemberment is
fine it's the rebellious eat my shorts
stuff that really made this show such a
danger to young minds instead they've
suggested the 1947 classic glenn ford
movie 200 miles to oregon glen ford
movies yes even the ones that don't
exist there's nothing wrong with your
television set you could not possibly
know if this is a true statement also
why are they just doing another twilight
zone parody they've done this before
they could at least parody something
different like tails from the dark side
or maybe even the outer limits hey look
i can see my voice jonathan's reaction
to the beginning of every recording of
behind the scenes somehow makes its way
into this episode front-facing child
seats in the front seat i'm honestly not
sure how any children survive the 90s
well it's been two long trips but we're
finally almost there again when you
locked the front door did you remember
to lock the back door you were there
marge this could have been addressed
then no homer's taking the brunt of this
but marge's timing on the questions is
straight up infuriating oh no we left
grandpa back at the gas station again
considering he was squished in the
backseat with you how is this just now
coming up i traveled on vacations with
my grandpa next to me i'd have known he
was missing just by the lack of casual
farting this is a terrible maze it's
basically two long straight paths
directly to the center this is less of a
shrub maze and more of a shrub hallway
you know you could just call the cable
company and cancel the service
scissoring smithers is very unnecessary
in this situation well get me up here
but why is mo a ghost at the hotel based
on what we saw with the three trips they
had to take at the beginning of the
episode this was not a short trip from
springfield i could understand mr burns
owning property all over the country but
i see no reason why mo would have been
this far away from his bar blah blah
blah alternate realities this is a
cartoon and then blah blah blah you're
still getting a sin considering homer's
lack of motivation and physical
limitations how did he manage to write
this legibly all over the ceiling and
where did he even get the giant
invisible ink sharpie i was thinking
along the lines of no tv and no beer
make homer something something go crazy
don't mind if i do
the first years of the simpsons are
possibly the best tv has ever been take
your sins off you crazy kids
homer survives this or at the very least
homer survives this without breaking his
neck or any part of his body marge is
able to carry homer for any distance hi
david i'm grandpa since they left
grandpa back at the gas station who took
him here a cab because i'd say the
chances of grandpa calling a cab that
would drive all the way out here are
minuscule and i super highly doubt that
he would even remember the place that
they were going is that a box of donuts
in dry storage not that homer cares but
those donuts would be staler than a
series of fortnight dances yeah yeah
homer's gonna kill his family i'm more
interested in the mystery of the
disappearing items from the table in the
previous shot there was a carton of milk
a pitcher of juice and the kids had
drinks in front of them look i'm not
gonna point out every inconsistency with
the original shining but i do feel the
need to say the picture above the bed
and the shining was a bit different all
i'm asking for is a bit more
authenticity you know because of my love
for film all right looney show me what
you got there are many things in this
episode that are hilarious but nothing
delights me more than the recurrence of
willy getting axed in each story
this is a large hotel with many rooms
why would you choose to escape outside
into the snow where you will almost
assuredly freeze to death television
teacher mother secret lover having sex
with your television come family sit in
the snow with daddy but why the hotel is
right
there live from broadway it's the tony
awards then why is it so cold everyone
knows the tony awards take place in june
everyone knows this
[Music]
why is the toaster still electrocuting
home or when it's unplugged correction
homer you're the second mr peabody and
sherman references and yes i know they
made a movie as recently as 2014 but
that only means more sins well that was
just one little insignificant mosquito
that can't change the future right no if
i've studied my koocher correctly it's
only butterflies that matter the more
important question is why didn't they
name this segment of the episode the
mosquito toast
guard dogs that can't catch homer
[ __ ] simpson mustn't listen but if he
goes back in time and doesn't change
anything else then ned is still ruling
the world he actually wants to change
something right even if he has to wish
and wish he kills that fish hey there's
a bug that looks like dad i have so many
questions about this future if they're
so huge why are they sitting in such a
small neighborhood did humans evolve to
be giants and have no concept of scale
and build houses they could never fit in
and do they just happen to rip the roof
off of this one right now for reasons
what is even going on here donut what's
a donut
[Music]
it's raining again
this show is another level in 10 seconds
they crafted a punchline ending worthy
of the best twilight zone episodes see
jordan it's not that hard during this
montage of changes to the simpsons house
why do all the other houses stay the
same
this maniacal laughs on for all the some
time coincidentally it's the exact
amount of some time needed to extend the
episode to network length what an
amazing turn of events if everyone eats
with lizard tongues that reach their
food from head to table in this reality
why are there forks and spoons and won't
they ask what happened to homer's tongue
and where did this reality's homer go
let's all turn our deaths backwards
before mrs krabappel shows up
how are you at all surprised bart even
if your eyes were closed which they
weren't how would you have not known you
were the only one doing this the dead
giveaway would have been when no one
else started turning their desks around
are you saying you killed jimbo
processed his carcass and served him for
lunch
quickly capitulating to killing and
cannibalizing kids mark does it strike
you as odd that odor disappeared and
suddenly they're serving us this
mysterious food called buddha rotten no
but i do find it odd that you're eating
it when there's almost a full cake
sitting right in front of you i'd be
going the distance on that thing instead
extremely funny title but how does this
cookbook give instructions on how to
cook milhouse if milhouse is still alive
why would edna need to know how to cook
milhouse if lunch lady doris is
preparing the meals why would a book
company publish recipes that have only
one use are there multiple milhouses
everywhere in the world we have apron on
skinner we have no apron on skinner i
believe i'll start as you've so often
suggested by
eating your shorts is that supposed to
be scary because that's good news right
here take my shorts while you're trying
to get those down i'll be putting some
distance between us if the runoff and
floor are this bloody how is the machine
so clean do they clean it between uses
because that seems like a huge job i've
got one of those normal sized magic
bullets and i spent a good hour trying
to get a random piece of strawberry out
of there are they even trying for
realism in this show
it was only a dream cliche why does
inside out march have blood vessels in
her hair wait does this mean her skull
goes all the way up to the top of her
hair do what would she look like without
the hair well now i really am going to
have nightmares
[Music]
inside out the musical
aren't you gonna offer me whatever it is
you taste like
hello once again
hi everybody
[Music]
we will control the horizontal
we will control the vertical mom is dad
gonna kill us your father's right
what will it be i'm awfully glad you
asked me that lloyd because i just
happen to have two 20s and 210s right
here in my wallet i was a little mad
sometimes we all go a little mad
sometimes
haven't you
hello
hello there who's that big man there
who's that stop talking brain thinking
hush
[Music]
we have to go back kate
tastes like
like strawberries
this is the inside story of your heart
and blood
lub-a-dubba and here to tell you about
it is the one and only slim good body